what next for Picard season 3 after
we've had so many hints about the
direction this series is gonna go what
do I think is going to happen and what
do you think welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel make it so
[Music]
unlike a few people out there that I'm
not at all jealous of I hate you all I
have not seen beyond the first episode
of Picard series 3. I do actually speak
to a couple of very lucky people that
have got the chance and I've had to ask
them not to tell me because
I don't want to ruin it I I just cannot
wait for this series and I'm really
really hopeful it's not going to let us
down the Way season one and season two
did but in the spirit of the excitement
of looking forward to this series I
thought I would do a little video I'll
talk about what has been hinted at from
the first episode and a few things that
I've picked up on that I think might be
telling us where the rest of the season
is going and I would love you guys at
the end to throw in your comments your
theories your ideas about where you
would like to see season three of Picard
go and maybe Beyond so first of all
let's have a think about some of the
things we saw in the first episode so
first of all let's quickly talk about
the Borg now there were several
references to the book but also
references to Wolf 359 now I think
that's going to be really really key and
I think that's where the Revenge element
of the main protagonist of the series
but we'll talk about her in a little
while is going to be coming from so
there was some subtle and not so
dimensions of wolf 359 for a start
Beverly crush's message to Picard even
though she said do not involve anybody
else from the Federation don't trust
anyone she dropped that little clue now
the clue that actually Picard had no
clue about now then Picard told Reicher
about the message and he knew almost
immediately it was a computer virus that
they had aboard the Enterprise D that
randomly added a three to all of their
navigational charts Etc so just played
Royal Havoc with all their navigational
systems he said now you wouldn't know
about it because it happened on the
Enterprise well you were incapacitated
life science
negative sir visual contact on screen
Picard looked stranger things were
incapacitated oh locutus now there's two
things I'd like to point out there
Picard was actually incapacitated aboard
the Enterprise D several times so I
don't know why he immediately jumped to
locutus when Riker just happened to
mention the news incapacitated but we'll
ignore that for a second another thing
why wouldn't Picard know that after the
locutus incident surely he would have
read all of the reports and one of the
reports would have been surely that they
had a computer virus that messed with
the navigational systems something they
didn't mention during the um Best of
Both Worlds episodes by the way but
we'll ignore that as well so this
slightly awkward little addition to
Beverly's message even though she knew
Picard wouldn't understand it unless she
spoke to Riker something she
specifically said not to do she said
trust no one but okay it did give the
writers the opportunity I believe just
to bring up locutus and by bringing up
locutus you point us back towards wolf
now there are also an Easter egg in the
final credits of Picard season three and
if you've looked at things like track
culture and their amazing breakdown of
the episode you'll probably know what
I'm talking about but during the final
sequence the um and all the little
images and things appears we see a
cloaking device we see all the lots of
other things we actually did see a
schematic of the USS constants the USS
Constance was reported missing in action
on stardate
4402.3 that is the star date of the wolf
359 battle so again a not so subtle hint
that that's where they're going with
this series of Picard that whatever the
captain of the shrike this Captain vatic
is so annoyed about and is so up for
blood over it's got to be something to
do with wall 359
so we'll talk about that a little bit
more in a second but while we mention
captain valak and her Battleship the
shrike let's have a Wonder
let's have a think about where that
vessel has come from so first of all we
actually see the ship and it's pretty
imposing it really reminds me of the
Scimitar from um Star Trek Nemesis you
know the big sticky out of hand and the
claws in there
52 disrupter Banks 27 Photon torpedo
Bays primary and secondary Shields
foreign
the shrike is a type of bird of prey
it's a little bird of prey and it's a
massive bugger it's only a couple of
inches big but he'll take on animals
much bigger than it and it's got this
thing it's got this really spiky beak
and it's known for like jabbing
into the back of their heads if it's
prey and slapping their necks nasty
little bird
um but
by calling it The striking by naming it
after a bird of prey do we assume can we
assume that this vessel is Romulan
origin now when I first saw the shrike
in the trailers run up to it I thought
it's Borg technology and I knew there
were going to be lots of Borg references
throughout the series but I have had a
thought since what if it's Romulan
hybrid Borg technology we know that the
Romulus have got the artifact they have
access to a borg Cube so they also have
access to Borg technology now from this
first season of Picard we're not really
sure what the state of the Romulan
Empire is We Believe they've lost the
Homeworld the Supernova the Federation
was going to try to evacuate their
Homeworld but kind of failed we also
know from season two though that they
still have commander of massive fleets
because we saw it
so the Romulan Empire is not on its
knees it's not dead it is still very
capable
perhaps this is a variant of the
Scimitar or perhaps it's advantage of
the Scimitar using very heavily bulk
technology we also know that from the
trailer when the shrike goes Toe to Toe
with the Titan a the Titan a gets its
ass handed to do it so this is going to
be a very capable Battleship it actually
looks like at one point the strike takes
on two Federation starships and Hans its
hands hands both of them they're ass so
very capable Starship so is this a
variant of the Scimitar potentially is
this a variant of the Scimitar though
with Borg technology well another
example we've got of that is actually
from season two the Stargazer was the
first Federation Starship to use Borg
technology so if the Federation were
doing it why wouldn't the romulans
so a borg Romulan hybrid warship built
by the Romulan Empire stolen Allah kind
of like what happened in Star Trek
Nemesis again well that would seem a
little unlikely would they do the same
plot mechanism again
but at the end of the day this vessel
has not just come from nowhere somebody
built it somebody with massive shipyards
so yeah romulans now another thing that
I think is very interesting is that we
have law and Moriarty in this series now
I've argued before that that doesn't
really make sense because we know that
law was disassembled
and shipped off to somewhere within the
Federation we also know that Moriarty
was well the last time we saw Moriarty
he was in a data Cube on board the
Enterprise D which then crashed but we
don't know that's where he was he might
have been moved but from the first
episode of season three we know that the
daystream Institute had secret
technology stolen from it secret
technology that could be used as a
weapon Rafi then sees that weapon
getting used this Quantum portal
technology which was one of the best
scenes in the episode how it's sort of
like and then bam oh it's
amazing now sometimes the daystream
Institute is also called The daystream
Institute of Robotics so all of a sudden
if this secret technology was stolen
from there wouldn't it make sense
actually that that's where the
Federation would send law for research
purposes and potentially send Moriarty
Moriarty being a sentient program so
surely for a robotics or anybody working
in artificial intelligence he would be a
very interesting character to research
so perhaps that's how law and Moriarty
end up in Picard Series in three because
they were stolen from The daystream
Institute along with the weapons that
we've already seen get used
now also Beverly Crusher talks a lot
about don't trust anything in within the
Federation don't trust anyone you can't
go to the Federation now that tends to
suggest that either what's going on
Beverly knows the Federation won't
support Picard or potentially that the
Federation has been infiltrated somehow
and that actually there are elements
within the Federation that will not be
on Picard's side
now again if the daystream Institute was
sort of burgled but that really make
sense or would it make more sense if
there is somebody on the inside of the
Federation that is supporting this
captain vatic and this weapons and this
technology was allowed to be taken so
again I think there's going to be more
than just an enemy potentially the
romulans attacking the Federation I
think there's going to be an element
from within the Federation that Picard
and
Etc need to deal with perhaps that's
where Rafi and wharf's storyline is
going before Wharf then ends up joining
the rest of the TNG crew but again going
back to the Battle of wolf 359 now
captain varic
says we've seen in the trailer hash
Jean-Luc Picard and it seems that Picard
recognizes her now we've not seen a
captain Vatican Star Trek before that I
remember so it's not going to be a
character that I think we directly know
but Picard does
now we also know that from sort of Star
Trek first Contact the Picard still
carries the scars of the locutus battle
and the scars of being a bork he feels
responsible for the attack at wool 359
and the 11 000 plus lives lost
perhaps Captain vatic also blames him
and wants to take her revenge
but I think Terry matalis is going to
have to be a lot cleverer than that it
cannot just be a straight or Revenge
plot there needs to be a lot more going
on because if you want revenge you don't
get hold of a warship like the shrike
and just go after Picard but we actually
know that's not the case anyway because
the shrike actually isn't going after
Picard
he's going after Beverly Crusher Beverly
Crusher who has dropped off the radar
for 20 years potentially just because of
her son
I don't know that would again be maybe a
little bit too obvious and I'm hoping
that's not the way we're going but he's
got an English accent so
but
the strike is going after Beverly so
Beverly knows something or is uncovered
something
Picard's involvement now is just because
Beverly called for help now that is
going to be something that Captain valik
would seem to be very happy about and
even though she might have a beef with
the Federation she 100 has a beef with
Picard too
so how is this all going to be pulled
together
I'd love for you to get into the
comments and tell me your theories where
am I right where am I wrong where are we
going in the next few episodes of Picard
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps the
same time and if you really want to
support the channel consider hitting the
join button also check the description
there's loads of links to our Facebook
page Tick Tock
um Discord server merchandise blah blah
blah blah go and check it all out as
always guys please stay safe enjoy Star
Trek and I'll see you next time
thank you
[Music]